please welcome to the stage Andrew house  thank you very much everyone it's an  absolute honor to be here at e3 our  mission is to make PlayStation the best  place to play for gamers and I think  you'll agree that this III marks one of  the strongest lineups of content in  PlayStation history that's a result of  our commitment to partnerships with the  most talented developers and  storytellers in our medium and as proof  of that commitment please join me in  welcoming one of the most creative  talents in the history of gaming  hello hello everyone I'm back today I  bring something new we move we made for  you and this is all running in gilt time  please enjoy  you  saintly  to take this  hello  sooner come  love sandals  for you mom  she  you